hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger
[Musique]
pour le trophée de la meilleure chanson
jamin castaldi
en vain
jean michel maire
toc toc qui est là claude gauthier à
claude françois banane si le sniper
officielle à l gens me demandent comment
voulez vous que je réponde ces gens
c'est cyril qui choisissent et mon amie
kelly
je nourris ni
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les trois géants
[Musique]
isabelle morini bosc oui je sais vous
m'appelez mamie qui font tant rêver mais
qu'elle est black de jean michel desplan
[Applaudissements]
isa benji
matt
max
et si le
[Musique]
avec obi là
g
[Musique]
d
et le gagnant est kelly g novelli
[Musique]